[موسيقى]
اذا الغيم تنهمر الحروف
لها نغم يحس به الشغوف
يرى فيها غصونا باسقات
على اطرافها تدنو القطوف
فان لبثت مقاليد المعاني مسطره تنوء بها
الرفوف
فتحنا في صميم العلم بابابا فقال الدهر قد
جاز الوقوف
[موسيقى]
يقولون معنى لا زكاه لماله وكيف يزكي
المال من هو باذله اذا حال حول لم تجد في
دياره من المال الا ذكره وفضائله تراه اذا
ما جئته متهللا كانك تعطيه الذي انت نائله
تعود بسط الكف حتى لونه اراد انقباضا لم
تطعه انامله فلو لم يكن في كفه غير نفسه
لجاد بها فليتق الله سائله السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
الفرق بين العلامه والاثر قالوا العلامه
تدل على الامر قبل حدوثه تقول الرياح
والغيوم علامات المطر اما الاثر فيدل على
الامر بعد حدوثه فنقول السيول اثار المطر
وعن الفرق بين الكابه والحزن قالوا ان
الكابه اثر الحزن البادي على الوجه فيقال
علته كابه ولا يقال علاه حزن او كرب لماذا
لان الحزن لا يرى ويكون في القلب وانما
دلالاته تكون ظاهره على الوجه وتلك
الدلالات تسمى كابه
يقول النابغه اذا حل بالارض البريه اصبحت
كئيبه وجه غبها غير طائل
[موسيقى]
قال الشاعر يجود علينا الخيرون بمالهم
ونحن بمال الخيرين نجود
وقصه هذا البيت ان بعض الخلفاء استدعى
شعراء مصر
فصادفهم شاعر فقير بيده جره فارغه كان
ذاهبا بها الى النهر ليملاها
فتبعهم الفقير حتى وصلوا دار الخلافه
فبالغ الخليفه في اكرامهم ثم راى الخليفه
ذلك الرجل والجره على كتفه ونظر الى ثيابه
الرثه وقال من انت وما حاجتك فقال ولما
رايت القوم شدوا رحالهم الى بحرك الطامي
اتيت بجرتي فقال الخليفه
املاوها له ذهبا وفضه فحسده بعض الحاضرين
وقالوا هذا فقير لا يعرف قيمه المال وربما
اتلفه وضيعه فقال الخليفه هو ماله يفعل به
ما يشاء
فخرج الرجل الى الباب ووزع المال كله على
الفقراء الذين لقيهم فبلغ ذاك الخليفه
فاستدعاه وعاتبه فقال للخليفه يجود علينا
الخيرون بمالهم ونحن بما للخيرين نجود
فاعجبه ذلك وامر انتم له عشر مرات وقال
الحسنه بعشره امثالها
[موسيقى]
البين هو الفراق والهجر والناحيه والفصل
بين الارضين والبين هو الوسط فنقول جلس
بين القوم اي وسطهم
وذات البين ما بين القوم من القرابه
والصله والموده او العداوه والبغضاء وغراب
البين يتشائم به لانه نذير الفرقه
والبين مسافه مد البصر والبين جاء في كلام
العرب على الوجهين فهو الفرقه وهو الوصل
في ذات الوقت يقول قيس ابن ذريح
لعمرك لولا البيت لانقطع الهوى
ولولا الهوى ما حن للبين الف
ويقول الشاعر الاندلسي ابن عبد ربه
ودعت فركب جناح البين في سفره هذا الفراق
وهذا الموت في اثره من يشتكي بين لا يشكو
غوائله قلب يراك اذا ما غبت عن بصره
وجاء في كتاب الله تعالى لقد تقطع بينكم
وظل عنكم ما كنتم تزعمون اي تقطع ما كان
بينكم ويقال بين بين بمعنى التوسط بين
الشيئين فيقال هذا الشيء ليس بجيدا ولا
رديء ولكنه بين بين
[موسيقى]
قيل ان اعرابيا اتى ديار قوم سائلا ثقيل
لقد وضع منك سؤالك فقال لقد سال موسى
والخضر اهل قريه فابوا ان يضيفوهما فوالله
ما وضع هذا من نبي الله وعالمه فكيف يضع
مني
[موسيقى]
قالوا استعمال الحلم مع اللئيم اضر من
استعمال الجهل مع الكريم واحسن من ذلك قول
ابي الطيب ووضع الندى في موضع السيف
بالعلى مضر كوضع السيف في موضع الندى
قالوا العدو عدوان عدوا ظلمته وعدو ظلمك
فان اضطرك الزمان الى ان تستعين باحدهما
فاستعن بالذي ظلمك فانه احرى ان يعينك لان
الذي ظلمته
موتور حاقد
[موسيقى]
التداخل بين العامي والفصيح امر يحصل
يوميا فنتنبه له احيانا واحيانا كثيره لا
نتنبه اليه قد يستغرب المرء مثلا اذا قرا
في نص فصيح عباره كهذه كنت اكون اسعد لو
انك جئت باكرا وهذا اسلوب فصيح وقويم
والغريب انه موجود في اللهجات العاميه ولا
يستهجنه احد ولكن قد ينكره عليك احدهم اذا
ما ذكرته بالفصحى وجه اخر ان العاميه تكره
المبنيه للمجهول فلا نقول عجن العجين بل
نستبدل وزن المطاوع فنقول ان عجن وقد نقول
اتعجن
ولا نقول قتل بل ان قتل والمصريون يقولون
اتقتل
على ان البدو في شبه الجزيره العربيه ما
زالوا الى يومنا هذا يستخدمون المبني
للمجهول احسن استخدام
لو اردنا ان نحصي الكلمات الفصيحه في
لهجات القبائل القديمه لوجدنا وجها من
اوجه الصواب لكل شيء وهذا بالطبع سيفتح
الباب على دفق من الخيارات وشبيه بهذا لو
جمعنا كلما في لهجات البلدان العربيه
وعددنا كل ذلك صوابا او حاولنا ان نجد
رابطا بينه وبين المعياري العربي
وبالحديث عن المعياري العربي اللغه
العربيه الفصحى المعاصره انطلقت من القران
الكريم بقراءاته المشهوره وتوسعت بما خطته
اقلام كبار الادباء والشعراء واختارت
طريقا وسطا حتى بلغ بنا الامر اننا اليوم
نسمع نشره الاخبار من المحطات العربيه من
المحيط الى الخليج فنرى ان الفصحى لغه
واحده وينذر ان تجد مصطلحا يستعمله
المشارقه يختلف عما يستعمله المغاربه يعني
ربما مثلا تجد ان اهل المغرب
يحبون ان يقولوا تحصل على بدلا من حصل على
ولكن حتى هذه تجدها الان اصبحت شائعه في
المشرق والمغرب ومثلها كلمه السنه
المواليه عند المغاربه وتقابلها السنه
التاليه عند المشارقه وهكذا هلم جر
[موسيقى]
يقول المثل صمت حصاه بدم فما قصه هذا
المثل
قال الاصمعي اصله ان يكثر القتل وسفك الدم
حتى اذا وقعت حصاه من يد راميها لم يسمع
لها صوت لانها لا تقع الا في دم فهي صماء
وليست تقع على الارض فيسمع لها صوت
وضربت العرب هذا المثل في الشر العظيم يقع
وفي الاسراف في القتل وكثره الدم وتجاوز
الحد
[موسيقى]
يروى عن اشعب انه استاذن على قوم ياكلون
حيتانا فقال احدهم ان من عاده اشعب طبعا
الحيتان يعني الاسماك
في سوره الكهف فلما بلغ مجمع بينهما نسيا
حوتهما هذا الحوت هو عباره عن سمكه كانت
معدل الغداء واهلنا في المغرب العربي الى
اليوم يقولون عن السمكه الحوت
فيروى عن اشعب انه استاذن على قوم كانوا
ياكلون الاسماك اي
الحيتان فقال احدهم ان من عاده اشعب ان
يبسط يده الى احسن الطعام فاجعلوا الحيتان
الكبيره بعيده عنه لياكل من صغار السمك
فلما دخل قالوا له ما رايك في الحيتان
يعني الاسماك قال انني حاقد عليها لان ابي
مات في البحر واكلته الحيتان قالوا له هلم
خذ بثارك منها
فجلس ومد يده الى حوت صغير ثم وضعه الى
اذنه هكذا وقال لقد اخبرني هذا الحوت انه
كان صغيرا عندما مات ابي وقال لي عليك
بتلك الحيتان الكبيره التي اخرتموها عني
فانها هي التي كانت قد شاركت في
في تلك الجريمه فمد يده
واكل معهم وكان له طريقه جميله دائما في
الاحتيال وفي طريقه التطفل على الناس
الذين ياكلهم دائما سواء كان برضاهم او من
غير رضا
[موسيقى]
كنت قد سالتكم في تويتر ما اجمل شعر قيل
في خطاب الله تعالى والثناء عليه وفيما
يلي استعرض معكم بعض ما وصلني من
مشاركاتكم هذه مشاركه من شامي يقول يا من
الوذ به فيما اؤمله ومن اعوذ به مما
احاذره لا يجبر الناس عظما ان تكاثره ولا
يهيضون عظما ان تجابره
مشاركه من عبد الرحمن يقول يا من يرى ما
في الضمير ويسمع انت المعد لكل ما يتوقع
يا من يرجى للشدائد كلها يا من اليه
المشتكى والمفزع يا من خزائن رزقه في
قولكن امن فان الخير عندك اجمع مالي سوى
فقري اليك وسيله
فبالفتقار اليك فقري ادفع مالي سوى قرعي
لبابك حيله فلان رددت فاي باب اقرع
ومشاركه ايضا من مصطفى علي ويقول ان
الابيات للشاعر حذيفه العرجي ثلث اخيرا
خلوه ودعاء ما شئت جل علا كلاما شاؤوا يا
رب ابواب اليك كثيره
وكثيره في داخل الاشياء
حملتها من سائل امنيه
وجميع نفسي ذله
ورجاءوا فقري اليك وسيلتي واجابتي
اغنى الخلائق عندك الفقراء
مشاركه ايضا من روان تقول الا كل شيء ما
خلا الله باطل وكل نعيم لا محاله زائل
وفرحان الفاعوري شارك معنا ايضا وقال على
عن الوصف من لا شيء يدركه وجل عن سبب من
اوجد السبب
وعبد ابو رمان يقول
ومما زادني فخرا وتيها وكت باخمص اطاء
الثريا دخولي في خطابك يا عبادي وان صيرت
احمد لي نبيا عليه الصلاه والسلام
وهدى تقول لك الحمد يا مستوجب الحمد دائما
على كل حال حمد فان لدائم
واسماعيل يشير الى قصيده بك استجير ومن
يجير سواك فاجر ضعيفا
يحتمي بحماك هذه القصيده الرائعه العظيمه
القصيده طويله ولكن طولها زادها حسنا
وفيها الكثير من الابيات
الجميله
المتادبه في خطاب الذات الالهيه والاشاره
الى اياته في السماء وفي الارض وفي النفس
البشريه
خالد يقول ولما قسى قلبي وضاقت مذاهبي
جعلت الرجا مني لعفوك سلما تعاظمني ذنبي
فلما قرنته بعفوك ربي كان عفوك اعظم
ومشاركه اخرى من ديانه ويبدو ان الابيات
مره ثانيه لحذيفه العرجي يا من تغير من
حال الى حال انجو بعفوك لا انجو باعمالي
رايت لطفك حتى حال معصيتي فاي حمد يجاري
فضلك العالي
وهنا عبد السلام بكار وله اكثر من مشاركه
يقول يا رب ما ناداك صوتي وحده قلبي بحبك
يا عظيم وينادي وفي مشاركه ثانيه يقول عبد
السلام يخيب الظن في كل البرايا ولكن فيك
ربي لا يخيب
وهذه اذا هي المشاركه
الاخيره من مشاركات اليوم
لم يبقى الا ان اشكركم على هذا التفاعل
الجميل وان اذكركم دائما بان تضعوا وسم
تاملات الجزيره واما محدثكم فيقول فخر
المفاخر انني لك مسلم ولقد مننت به بغير
سؤال فاجب دعائي ان سالتك جنه ليست تبلغني
لها اعمالي
[موسيقى]
هذه قصه عبد مملوك اصبح باشا ثم اصبح
الصدر الاعظم في عهد السلطان عبد الحميد
الثاني
خطف الطفل في فتنه حدثت في ابخازيا وتقع
اليوم في جمهوريه جورجيا ثم جاء به الى
اسطنبول فاشتراه تحسين بيك التركي وجعله
رفيقا لولده ومات ولده وكان المملوك قد
بلغ السابعه عشره فباعه تحسين بك الى
مندوب حاكم تونس الباي احمد باشا
ركب الفتى خير الدين البحر الى تونس وعاش
في بلاط الباي سيصبح وزيرا وسفيرا وسينال
القابا كثيره وسوف يستقيل مرارا
لكنه كان يحمل في صدره موهبته الكبيره
تقلب بين التركيه والعربيه والفرنسيه وطاف
دول اوروبا ومكث في فرنسا بضع سنين
كان مولد خير الدين التونسي في السنه التي
مات فيها نابليون وعاش حتى قارب السبعين
وعندما كان في اواسط الاربعين من عمره كتب
كتابه المشهور
طبع كتاب اقوم المسالك في معرفه احوال
الممالك في تونس بالعربيه وترجم الى
الفرنسيه ثم بعد زمن طويل الى الانجليزيه
والكتاب كله في وصف دول اوروبا وانظمه
الحكم فيها واحوال الشعوب والدساتير
ويتميز كتاب خير الدين التونسي عن كتاب
رفع الطهطاوي تخليص الابريز في تلخيص
باريس وهو اقدم الكتابين كتاب رفاعه يعني
بان رفاعه الطهطاوي كان اماما فنظر الى
فرنسا بعين الدهشه ووصف احوالها اما خير
الدين فكان رجل دوله فتعمق في احوال كل
الدول الكبرى في اوروبا كان يريد استقاء
الافكار وذهنه منصرف الى كيفيه النهوض
ببلدان الشرق
يناقش خير الدين التونسي في مقدمه الكتاب
مشكلات الشرق ويقتبسوا من ابن خلدون ويعبر
عن فكره الاساسي وهو اننا يجب ان ننهض
نهضه اصيله لا مستورده ثم تتوالم مئات
الصفحات وكلها عن البلدان
الاوروباويه كما يدعوها خير الدين نراه
يتحدث عن الثوره الفرنسيه فيذكر اعدام
الملك لويس السادس عشر يذكر ذلك في سطر
واحد فقط
فاما عشرات الصفحات الاخرى عن فرنسا فهي
تاريخ سياسي
واجتماعي ونظر عميق في الدستور يلح خير
الدين في تعقب الثوره الفرنسيه التي
اختطفها نابليون ويروي كيف اعادت فرنسا
الملكيه وقارئ هذا الفصل عن فرنسا يتعلم
درسا مهما هو ان الثوره على الحكم الظالم
لا تنجح من المره الاولى يقول خير الدين
ان الثوره الفرنسيه
جاءت لتؤسس حريه الانسان بينما جاءت
الثوره الانجليزيه التي يسمونها الثوره
المجيده لتنظم الدوله ويطرح مثالا طريفا
كان الملك البريطاني جورج الثالث مجنونا
ولكن بريطانيا في زمنه كانت في احسن
احوالها فانتصرت في حروب كبيره واصبحت
اغنى بلد في العالم فكيف ذلك السبب انها
كانت دوله تنظيمات وهذا ما نسميه اليوم
بدوله المؤسسات المؤسسات العميقه
لو كتب مؤرخون المعاصرون كتبهم بطريقه خير
الدين التونسي لكن احسن ثقافه كان ينظر
الى الاسباب والنتائج وكان يحلل بفهم عميق
المملوك الذي اصبح الصدر الاعظم
[موسيقى]
ارسلت بالقول الاغر رساله يحكي بها
التاريخ في اليوم الاغر
واجبت مبتدا الزمان بدره ضاءت بابياتي على
مد النظر انا يكف القول دون مؤمل وانا
الذي جوهرت قولي بالدولار
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]